okay I'm told we can go to H ABD Hamid
Al shaz's ABD Hamid in rala h we're
we're watching a lot of live pictures
right now in this rapidly
moving this rapidly moving situation
you're in
rala
okay sorry we're going back to occupi
Jerusalem because this is the live scene
of the apartment the family
apartment this is the scene we were just
watching where everybody had to be
silent
let's let's take this in for a moment
this
14-year-old if you've been with us the
last 10 15 minutes you know what this is
about we were we're in the apartment
right now this is the live shot of a
family in occupied East Jerusalem who
got notified today that there are son
14-year-old that you see right now in
the center of the shot would be released
and here it is a lot of tension the last
15 minutes just before he made it here
before he arrived and was returned to
his family because everybody was afraid
that all of this would be disrupted by
Israeli law enforcement but here he
is no Al jaaz Muhammad Jam has been
walking us through this the last few
moments Muhammad I don't know if I don't
know if you can hear me at this point
can you hear me Muhammad
oh I hear you s
yes can you hear me I hear you yeah yeah
mamed I can hear you I have to say
really emotional
scenes okay it seems they're asking
they're asking let me let me explain to
you what's happening just a
couple so this so this is the arrival
of Bo who had been in prison for
months finally arrived home again s this
just goes to show how everything changes
here for these family in instant it was
just a couple minut ago you and I were
talking and I was talking about the
scene of panic that set in here because
everybody was convinced Security Forces
might ra this home at any moment they
were outside they were circling the home
it looked like they were going to the
upstairs apartment nobody knew what was
going to happen if they were going to be
kicking out the journalist now just a
couple of minutes ago the arrival
ahed he was Minister detention he had
been acced accused of throwing stones at
a car full of Israeli settlers injuring
female Israeli settler uh he had he had
he had been first under house arrest
then under administrative detention now
one of the youngest Palestinian
prisoners who have been released under
this captives and prisoners swap overall
ceasefire deal between Israel and Hamas
now he has been released again sirel
these are very dramatic scenes you see
the family members who have for hours
now been worried about whether ahed
would actually be released he is finally
home and they are so grateful uh they
are tearful they are hugging him you're
seeing tears of sadness tears of joy uh
you are seeing just people overflowing
with emotion at this moment everybody
now trying to
speak because they want to see he has to
say um we're going to try to
moments let's see if he starts speaking
into the microphone one of his relatives
it looks like he's going to start
talking right now I don't know if you'll
be able to hear this or not just give us
a minute to find
out we're with you you can hear it so
once he starts
speaking but yes S as I was saying oh
here we go here we
go
[Music]
aldd praise be to
Allah for His blessings that he bestows
on all of humanity praise be to Allah
for the liberation of my son Ahmed from
the occupation
prisons thanks to the prisoner swap
agreement
between resistance and the occupation
government my son Ahmed has been in
prison for four months following two
months of house
arrest apology signal is cutting out
from the
source
is nothing compared to actual prison
however we refus house arrest in order
not to lengthen the Detention of our
son's
inside prisons so thankfully we refused
house arrest and my son Ahmed and his
two cousins were handed over on July
30th to the Deon
prison during that period as a former
liberated detainee I was prohibited from
visiting my son and the same thing for
um Muhammad Muhammad's mother because
her ID is from the West Bank even she
has a residency permit in the occupation
state so throughout ahmed's stay in
prison we were not able to visit him
even though he is the youngest
Palestinian detainee he is 14 years
old when the war started on October
7th we lost contact with our son and all
our detainees as well as our female
detainees inside occupation prisons we
were extremely
concerned we were anxious we were
hearing receiving information on
torture on children being put in
solitary confinement we did not know
where our children were over the past 50
days thankfully after 5 days of Truth
they were released we would like to
thank each and everyone who sacrificed
his soul for the safety of all of our
sons
your son is a child
DET yes he is a child detain but he is
also the youngest detain he is 14 years
old when he was first arrested he was
under 14 years of
age after turning 14 he was remanded in
custody and I handed him to the author
of the Demonic prison which is the exact
same prison that I was in 30 years ago
and thanks to Allah he was released
today
Ahmed how was your situation in the last
days of
imprisonment look at the camera
please say whatever you wish you've
lived through this experience tell us
what happened to you how was the
situation when did you know you were
going to be released 2 hours ago so it
wasn't yesterday it wasn't a week ago it
wasn't 10 days
ago so what happened to you when the war
started how did you know about what
happened they closed all
departments and at the person I was at
there was the female section
on day one we heard women who were being
[Music]
beaten we were
beaten and a unit was coming to beat us
but uh they were stopped from doing that
and we stayed like that from October 7th
until today what about food what about
communication what about contacts with
your families we only receive two meals
per day
and we would often go hungry we had
nothing or no means to contact our
families we were only allowed outside
once excuse my son he is very nervous I
think he is lost 10 kilogram over the
past four months at least 10
kilograms how did they inform you guys
that you're going to be
released they asked us to come quickly
every once in a while they were taking
people out so you were suspecting that
you were going to be released soon
yes